hi we hope you're now all excited to
build scalable applications using App
Engine and the Google cloud platform in
this lesson we'll get down to the nuts
and bolts of everything and have you
deploys your first code to App Engine
this will involve a number of different
steps but don't worry we'll all do it in
a structured and orderly fashion to make
sure you're on your way to become a
rockstar App Engine developer so let's
look at what we're going to do in this
lesson first we're going to look at the
App Engine development cycle it creates
an app engine project where you can
upload your code then we're going to
look at cloud endpoints that allows you
to create a back-end that can work with
any front-end device technology after
that we'll get you started with a
development environment where you
develop code for App Engine and then
we'll introduce conference central the
application that we will build out
throughout this course at the end of
this lesson you'll have a working
application running in the Google cloud
isn't that exciting let's go shall we